[Music]
hey paul welcome to the show
hey john and rachel thank you how are
you guys doing today we're doing great
how are you paul
um i'm feeling pretty stressed and torn
with a family and money situation i was
hoping to get your thoughts and advice
on it yeah we'd love to help what's
what's going on okay so
um i'm wondering if i should
quit my side job to spend that time
instead with my wife and newborn baby
girl or should i keep working the side
job considering we just started baby
step 2 this week and we have about 245
000 of debt
what's it in
uh 128 of that is mortgage and the rest
is student loans personal loans car
loans credit card
okay all the fun stuff yep yep okay real
quick will you break down all the debt
not cleaning the mortgage
but break do you have the numbers for
your for credit card all that okay
yeah i've got about 1800 in credit card
we have uh
3 250 to a personal loan
about 3
500 left on a car
uh
student loan for my wife is about 11 000
a hvac home improvement loan for about
12 000
a parent plus loan that i agreed to pay
back for my mom that's 16 000 and then
my student loans are about 70 000 wow
you got you got a little bit of
everything paul
nice nice little variety what do you do
for a living man
uh i am a uh
manager at a non-profit that provides
free clothing boutique for foster
children wow that's awesome
and how much how much do you make a year
doing that
i make a little over 45 000 and then my
wife is a third grade teacher
she makes about 67 000. okay is she
gonna go back
uh she is back um
and she's also in grad school to be a
school counselor okay we have cash flow
in that which we're cash flowing it's
cash flowing okay awesome
so the side job was to kind of help pay
for the cash flowing the grad school and
the added cost of child care
okay so when i started it was actually
pretty
decent pain but it's i'm my side job is
i'm a custodian at a local gym and now
that i know how to do everything and it
doesn't take me nearly as long it just
doesn't pay as much because it's hourly
okay
um but you're using that
side gig money from what you said for
child care
uh and grad school so is that money
already is there anything extra that you
have that's going to the debt or is that
that all that money from the side get
going too
um
yeah
with the budgeting we realized that we
could essentially live on just one
income and we were just kind of living
in that stupid
where we just were spending money that
we didn't have on things that we didn't
need yeah um so we're able to pay
toward our snowball but i'm just i don't
want to make it last any longer from the
math i'm like it's already going to take
five years
i just what's your degree in what's your
degree in paul
uh i have a bachelor's in family studies
okay
so
rachel
can i hop in here oh please do yeah yeah
yeah okay paul i'm gonna just cut to the
chase is that cool
yeah okay
you're broke
and you're you're scary broke
okay
um i know you know that
but i want to say it that starkly
this
you're gonna have to get a job the place
you work at right now is an
extraordinary mission
and it's like you being there is a gift
to the people that you serve
and
you
are in a financial position that you
cannot afford to do that type of work
right now and and support your family
you have
an emergency your house is on fire
and inside your house having a having a
bible study or cooking food for the
homeless would be great but right now
your house is on fire you need to get
out of the house
okay
okay you're gonna have to find work
where you can get this stuff paid off
fast fast fast
it might mean that we're gonna pause
grad school for a minute because the
house is on fire
it might mean that i'm going to stop
doing um
this part-time job here and i'm going to
get a full-time job making 60 000 and
then i'm going to go work the late shift
from 5 p.m till 11 30 at mcdonald's and
make 20 bucks an hour on a sign i saw
the other day
i'm gonna work like crazy for 20 20
months 24 months and we're going to get
this thing knocked out so that i can
spend tons of time full presence no
anxiety no anxiousness no it's all
coming down
the next time you have a air conditioner
fail it's going to be annoying not a a
alone a heloc
and then you're going to be able to
breathe around your baby
that's what i'm suggesting okay
yeah that's the level of radical life
transformation your baby deserves you
deserve your wife deserves your marriage
deserves everybody does
i mean sorry no no no no it's it because
it because the mat when you just look at
the math right john does a
great job bringing in the the reality of
the emotional state and what and what's
going on inside of you but but also paul
the the numbers
you just have you guys just have a small
shovel
with a really big hole it's kind of what
it is right so i'm just like how can we
fill in this hole of debt faster more
efficiently for you and your family
because that's who i want you taking
care of first and foremost before anyone
else and i yeah whether it's i mean
foster care adoption homelessness uh
human trafficking and all of these
things in the world um when we can plug
ourselves into those things and make the
world better we are all for all four
but not at the detriment we gotta get
our house of your family first and
foremost you know so even if it's for
18 months that you go and work a job
that you're like oh i hate those but
it's paying a ton and i'm sacrificing
what i love and what my mission is for
the moment
just to clear all this out and and wipe
it out then i get to actually what john
was saying i get to breathe and be like
okay we have margin i have margin in my
life now and so yeah i can take a pay
cut and go work somewhere that i really
feel called to because i actually can i
can do that and take care of my family
um but the quickest way you're gonna
change the scenario paul really is is is
the income side uh getting it up in the
side gig
if there's something that pays more or
you can do it quickly for two hours and
you go over to another side gig
and i know your your initial question
though was
do i keep all of that
or spend time with my family and i think
it can be both i think that yes you are
in the middle of sacrifice right now
time wise
uh to clean up this financial
um hole that you guys are in by knocking
out these debts and these are some small
debts that's why i loved it like the
credit card debt you're gonna pay that
off you're gonna stay motivated and from
someone who's dad and parents my mom my
dad worked all the time when i was
little all the time paul doing all of
this stuff i mean but i never felt like
i had an absolute dad because when he
was around he was present fully with you
fully with me so i think you can still
be a great dad and work your tail off
for 18 to 24 months to clear this dead
out but i appreciate your call
appreciate the work that you do what's
on your heart because it's incredible
absolutely incredible this is the ramsay
show